eu me chamo ynet tenho 30 anos sou mãe
me considero neurocientista provocação
professora por paixão e psicóloga de
formação
eu sou portadora do transtorno de
personalidade limítrofe ou mais
conhecido como borderline o mórbido com
depressão e fobia social
o transtorno de personalidade borderline
se caracteriza por um padrão de emoções
instáveis impulsividade de grandes
exageros quanto ao uso do álcool drogas
e sexo
a gente não fez uso de drogas não há
sustos e sofrimento e agressividade
relacionados a ser contrária a tal medo
não tentem mesmo em pequenas coisas do
que chamado nos manuais de humor
caprichoso
há também o comportamento
auto-destrutivo infelizmente e uma
terrível autoimagem vocês podem estar
achando muito fofinha essa noite mas eu
estou me achando horrível o que é ser
auto destrutivo pra mim no meu caso ter
uma gastrite que é agravada pelo uso de
café quando chega em casa no fim do dia
eu tenho uma garrafa de café inteira
auto imagem ruim como já falei pra vocês
não acreditar quando ninguém me chama de
bonita eu encontro qualquer defeito meu
corpo me pessoa viveu tempo todo mesmo
que as pessoas falam o contrário
esse transtorno ele atinge de 1 a 2% da
população na sua maioria mulheres está
relacionado com o histórico de abuso
sexual psicológico e negligência na
infância
infelizmente eu passei por todas as
experiências para mim esse transtorno
desculpa para mim esse transtorno tem a
ver com não confiar em ninguém acreditar
que todos vão me prejudicar tem a ver
com parar as coisas na metade e ter
querido desistir muitas vezes do curso
que eu tanto desejei a maioria dos
borderline se fala em um grande vazio
esse vazio pra mim é não me senti
recompensada por nada não gostar
nia não gostar da minha comida preferida
não ficar feliz com os meus sonhos se
realizam
eu gostaria de falar aqui pra vocês hoje
como é viver com transtorno de
personalidade começar e concluir uma
graduação em psicologia com esse
transtorno que têm como padrão de
existência contínua mudança de objetivos
mas hoje eu quero contar pra vocês um
pouco da minha história eu nasci bem no
interior do mato grosso onde
praticamente nada chega pra vocês terem
uma idéia no primeiro contato com a
internet foi em 2006 e somente no ano de
2014 eu fui no cinema pela primeira vez
o meu pai ele é alcoólatra inveterado
ele é uma pessoa muito agressiva e
intolerante ele gastava todo o salário
dele com bebidas e prostitutas
podíamos apanhar em casa ter todas as
coisas destruídas a qualquer momento por
isso eu tenho uma frase bom soldado ele
se mantém de pé ele não dorme nós
ficarmos sempre em alerta
quando eu ficava doente atá detalhe meu
pai matou os bichos de estimação meu e
quando eu ficava doente geralmente eu
não era tratada e eu podia foi assim os
sintomas incomodassem meu pai no caso
agora como eu estou com a voz anasalada
gripada se eu torci se podia apanhar
passamos fome em muitas vezes e aos 15
anos eu me casei para sair de casa mas
infelizmente não deu certo e os 18
voltei pra casa com tudo isso eu me
escondi nos livros estudar seria a forma
de ser bem lista foi muito aplicado aos
meus estudos mas a faculdade mais
próxima da minha cidade era 150
quilômetros e o que eu ganhava só dá pra
pagar meu aluguel na época porém muito
teimosa em 2009 eu fui fazer a faculdade
mas não tive dinheiro pra pagar
então eu percebi que a única forma de
estudar era ter uma bolsa 100% e assim
eu fiz o enem
consegui uma bolsa 100% do prouni e
disse que iria para cuiabá
eu recebi muitas
críticas pelo que eu estava fazendo meu
segundo marido que agora é isso
na época disse que não viria eu disse
que vinha sozinho com a minha filha ele
decidiu ouvir então a gente veio de
carona com as nossas coisas encaminham
de frango congelado é efetivo aqui com o
cheirinho de galinha gelada né pra casa
pequena que não cabe os móveis porque a
pessoa que vos fala do interior me aluga
casa sem olhar a distância chega aqui a
casa tem uma peça então ficou tudo no
quintal ea gente dentro da casa mas aqui
eu caminhava longas distâncias para ir
para a faculdade porque eu não tinha o
dinheiro para pagar o vale-transporte e
eu não estava conseguindo quase livre na
época o time anos oito quilômetros todo
dia para ir e voltar da minha casa mas
aí em 2011 parecia que a minha vida ia
eu fiz uma seletiva e eu consegui um
emprego muito muito concorrido
havia uma empresa que ela estava abrindo
uma nova filial e essa empresa de
materiais para a construção é muito
grande aqui no mato grosso e no paraná e
teve 800 candidatos para 25 vagas e eu
tinha experiência então a pergunta é
como foi que a pessoa do interior que
não tinha experiência nenhuma conseguir
essa vaga
eu me lembro que eu sempre fui muito
corajosa e eu fui passando nas etapas a
última etapa é um palco como esse dia 30
candidatos ea gerência ficou embaixo e
eles falaram assim pra gente cada um de
vocês vai nos tentar vender um produto
estiver com vocês esse produto não pode
ser repetido
e como eu sou muito sortuda que por
último né
aí quando chegou a minha vez todo mundo
já tinha vendido que era tudo que era
brinco que ela até maquiagem da cara da
pessoa menina tinha vendido
aí falei agora tinha uma pedra no meu
sapato incomodando
tirei a pedra levou vender a pedra pra
vocês agora eu falei essa pedra ela
serve para ser usada na construção serve
também é bonito olha aqui uma pedra em
linda ela eu falei ela tem uma função
incrível quando você está em uma
multidão ver o seu amigo
não consegue chamá lo você capta pedra
atua nele então com certeza eu olhar
para trás e assim não conseguiu emprego
e esse emprego é a gente né a pessoa
doida mas consegue emprego
esse emprego ele me possibilitou ter uma
vida mais estável nem estava com uma
vida mais estabilizada
porém eu tinha uns amigos no trabalho
sou poxa você fala que queria fazer
psicologia fixa não tenta lei não é pra
mim eu estava quase terminando outra
faculdade do prouni não faz o enem eu me
propus pra mim mesmo
falei que em sete anos que eu terminei o
ensino médio se eu não passar porque não
era pra ser mas eu passei entrei em
psicologia na federal
a primeira de toda a minha família a
entrar numa faculdade federal
naquele momento eu me senti como se
tivesse ganhado o nobel
[Aplausos]
mas é como tudo na vida da gente não são
flores passar em psicologia e fez
escolher entre o meu sustento e o meu
sonho
larguei meu emprego porque o curso é
integral
o meu marido na época e decidiu ir
embora porque ele disse que não ia
sustentar a casa sozinho eu fiquei no
curso dos meus sonhos sem emprego sem
marido sem esperança
como a filha pequena para criar longe de
todos os que eu conhecia eu passei fome
novamente e no dia que ele ia sair de
casa eu me lembro que ele falou assim eu
ia comer merda eu estava numa situação
tão difícil eu acabei tentando suicídio
três vezes deu certo eu tô aqui há seis
anos é muito boa nisso ok mas então no
segundo ano de curso finalmente essa
pessoa que falou tem coisa errada e eu
aceitei no psiquiatra achei que é
melhorar e ele me passou os remédios
mais a medicação no início há quase de
mata porque ela tem que fazer a curva
até a curva de adaptação então assim eu
estudava muito mais as minhas notas só
caiu e os meus sonhos eu ia se afundando
11 que eu tava com a manta muito baixo
eu falei assim eu vou reclamar
era como se não pudesse vencer eu
abandonei várias provas me machucando em
surtos de ansiedade e eu fui pedir ajuda
alguns professores porque eu tava no
curso de psicologia
mas o que eu me por incrível que pareça
foi alguém como você não devia estar
estudando é muito estressante
ou senão a professora falava assim essa
nota que tds 5 foi porque eu me
compadeci para você passar hoje estarão
se sentindo mal só foi piorando a
situação e uma história muito engraçada
que hoje o dou risada mas na época foi
muito estressante
antes foi que a gente tinha uma
disciplina por nome de psicopatologia no
geográfica onde tem que não ser ensinado
o dsm que o diagnóstico de transtornos
mentais e eu queria muito que ela
assinasse porque preciso desmistificar
as doenças você precisa conhecer ela era
contra
eu lembro que um dia tive um surto na
aula dela teve uma crise e ela disparou
vocês estão vendo aí o ps m faz com a
pessoa gente louca
enquanto arrancava um pedaço da parede
me cortava obviamente que não estávamos
sendo nabarro morreu é que chamou de
louca pra você quando só ter sido assim
né
mas no fim eu carrego uma história de
preconceito por ser negra e pobre
isso não é novidade você ser negro no
brasil não é fácil ser pobre - ainda mas
eu descobri outro preconceito contra as
pessoas que têm problemas mentais e
nesse momento eu nunca me sentir tão
sozinha mesmo cursando psicologia mas as
coisas na minha vida começaram a entrar
no eixo quando no segundo ano do curso
eu conheci uma disciplina de
neurofisiologia e o professor que
lecionava essa matéria ele está ali
aliás agradeço a ele que ele pediu uma
das minhas tentativas de suicídios não
fosse ele eu não estava aqui
e foi nesse momento que eu percebi que
teu dest biológico que eu tinha e
cognitivo não era o meu fim
na verdade seria uma oportunidade de
aprender mais e fazer diferente
nesse momento eu comecei a minha
caminhada me tornei autodidata e falei
vou saber tudo do meu transtorno
vou explicar para vocês o que eu estou
chamando de déficit cognitivo
eu sempre fui uma aluna exemplar não era
tão ruim a gente sem falar da doença
mental mas eu estava com dificuldades
sérias na universidade
eu sempre perguntava os meus colegas em
que como professora dizer com aquilo
esse material que eu não entendi o
recado por burra vem com uma porta e eu
vi o pessoal fazendo tudo sem
dificuldade
mas a depressão sina que o transtorno eu
já tenho uma questão 2 lateral por isso
que eu sou bem consequente mas aí vem a
depressão que ela afeta o córtex e essa
área do córtex ela é utilizada para a
gente prestar atenção formar memória
manusear informações
o acadêmico normal dia a dia está
prestando atenção ele está aprendendo
agora pra mim um negócio você então a
gente depressão é muito mais do que está
triste e eu entendi que meu cérebro não
está funcionando como deveria e eu já
estava em tratamento nessa época o que
controlou bastante ideação suicida não
terminou ela mas controlou sempre aquela
coisa os pensamentos bem mas eu falo
hoje não é dia de morrer
quanto ao rendimento acadêmico a
medicação piorou mas eu falei assim bem
agora tem que descobrir o que vai
funcionar pra mim o que não vai nessa
jornada tornei me o terapeuta eu faço a
minha auto terapia é muito engraçado
porque eu brigo comigo mesmo diariamente
a gente entra numa discussão é de r nós
duas aqui as 12 net briga feia mas assim
eu descobri que o isolamento freqüente
que isso é parte do meu transtorno e
fazia ter mais tempo pra ficar
pesquisando e lendo e desta forma foi
aumentando os meus conhecimentos
eu aprendi que as chamadas limitações
não determina os meus limites de fato
porque o governo ainda é um transtorno
limítrofe
então falei não vai determinar então
assim à medida que a depressão estava
melhorando eu fui me tornando
especialista em conexões da psicologia
com as neurociências
eu tenho pra dizer pra vocês é todo o
conhecimento é poder
não importa qual ele seja quando foi que
a minha vida andou no ano de 2015
fiquei sabendo do curso de neurociências
da universidade federal do rio grande do
sul
então assim eu já era autodidata em
neurociências eu falei vou escrever só
que é um curso muito concorrido o brasil
inteiro se inscreve tinha carta de
intenção tinha currículo meu latim não
era grande coisa mas eu
fui e pela minha carta de intenção eles
não escolheram
e assim foi
cara uma loucura porque se foi minha
primeira viagem de avião
assim imagina uma pessoa do interior que
eu conhecia elevador bem pouco tempo
aliás é um trabalho pra mim aprender
como funciona essa é outra história
o cara tá no céu assim pra mim foi lindo
é uma imagem que eu nunca vou esquecer a
diferença sim dá que eu falo alguma
coisa mais bonita que o céu pra mim são
os olhos da minha filha ea viagem foi
maravilhosa
esse curso ele mudou a minha vida porque
eu conseguir participar dele com
excelência porque eu acreditava que não
ia conseguir causa dos meus problemas
nos problemas de saúde os problemas
mentais
ele teve um trabalho final eu consegui
apresentar com certo sucesso e assim
conhecer neurociências me apresentou
novas possibilidades uma nova visão de
trabalho de mundo acadêmico então eu
voltei eu falei eu tenho que levar para
os meus colegas e eu tenho que trazer
isso pra cá então eu fundei o primeiro
curso de extensão em neurociências do
mato grosso foi um sucesso graças a deus
eu tive muitos alunos tanto da
universidade como da comunidade quando
eu digo tive muitos alunos sim porque
fui eu que dei aula
foi muito gratificante pra mim e eles
tiveram oportunidade pela primeira vez
de aprender sobre neurociências e como
ela é capaz de contribuir para o nosso
dia a dia e tudo isso é gratuito fiz um
curso grátis e assim as maiores
premiações que foi meu reconhecimento
acadêmico todo meu esforço foi que no
ano de 2017
eu escrevi o meu trabalho porque em um
congresso internacional do trabalho de
conclusão de curso que a ansiedade o uso
do álcool como medicação auto-medicação
a metanálise para esse congresso foi
enviado 1.089 trabalhos foram
selecionados 823 e apenas 50 foram
publicados numa revista internacional
esses números que mandou pra mim foi a
moça tá não fui eu que contando
de forma nenhuma que tipo meu deus como
eu sou [ __ ] o desculpa não só o açaí ela
que mandou pra mim pra falar olha
parabéns olha como o seu trabalho
importante né
e assim eu fiquei muito feliz com essa
realização e nesse mesmo ano eu me
formei com quatro anos e meio de curso
a primeira do curso formal antes do
tempo porque o tempo de formação mínima
da psicologia são cinco anos
e pra mim foi inacreditável para alguém
condenado os limites das emoções todas
as emoções que eu tive fortes boas ruins
e contrárias
eu me formei antes do previsto mas as
emoções não está e eu falo pra você
assim se as limitações mas não determina
os meus limites de fato que eu sempre
tive como uma grande maldição na vida
que é ser doente mental
eu chorava chorava nos intervalos da
aula se converteu numa bênção na clínica
eu atendo na clínica apesar de tudo isso
é loucura isso me traz uma vantagem
enorme para tratar os pacientes pois a
minha empatia e capacidade para entender
o transtorno de cada homem faz atender
diferente né
sempre que o terapeuta vou falar pra
vocês não tem fórmula mágica no seu
curso superior face e psicologia essa é
a fórmula mas não tem outra ter uma
vivência com transtornos mentais e faz
ter uma sensibilidade acima da média
para dizer o que é certo na hora certa
sabem ensinar o que fazer no momento em
que é preciso intervir na medida da
necessidade
eu fui taxada muitas vezes de incapaz
não foi uma nem duas vezes aliás a minha
história de vida se baseia em quantas
pessoas diziam que eu não podia mas eu
provei pra mim mesma que eu não sou isso
é importante você não precisa provar
para o outro você precisa provar pra
você a fobias real ela me roubou a
capacidade de aproveitar os amigos mas
ela me trouxer capacidade de estudar
sozinha maior foco maior dedicação à
depressão infelizmente ela
não me permitiu desfrutar das alegrias
da formação mas ela me permitiu ajuda a
os meus colegas quando ele estava em um
momento de tristeza
o transtorno de personalidade borderline
e roubou a chance de estabelecer lucros
ao mesmo que ele mostrou que nem sempre
na vida se trata de você está vinculado
alguém a maldição pode ser uma bênção
a primeira vez que eu vi isso eu fiquei
chocada foi só pode ser um absurdo
porém nesses cinco anos de carreira
acadêmica
posso dizer com certeza que é uma
verdade jamais teria noção da
importância da saúde mental
mesmo tendo se feito psicologia se eu
não tivesse o transtorno de
personalidade borderline junto com a
depressão ea fobia social sentir na pele
faz toda a diferença
o do olhar que eu recebi e recebo
quando eu falo da minha mente do e se dá
porque às vezes eu falo brincando a
pessoa leva muito a sério mas ela pega o
dsm paralelas à corrente parte de mim
messi me faz querer cada dia mais
desmistificar os transtornos é
necessário falar
não se pode querer ser igual quando
nascemos para ser diferentes
teve um tempo que eu acreditei muito na
cura até entender que não há cura para
personalidade
então é fazer o possível já que é
impossível não depende de mim
entendo hoje que a psicologia não só
deve entender o psicológico mas todas as
dimensões do ser humano em especial a
ligação do biológico que chamamos de
pensamento
os limites são aqueles que acreditamos
que temos como vocês podem ver meu
cabelo tem limite olha como ele tá né
claro que tem um transtorno mental fazer
as coisas muito mais difíceis e disse
difíceis mesmo dia de você brigar com
você mesmo de rolar no chão mas não são
impossíveis mas tudo
sempre tem um lado bom o bom da minha
doença é que eu aprendi que toda
conquista mas naquela pareça essa
operação
sabe aquele dia que eu consegui sair
onde a vizinho nem nossa eu falei com
alguém e até que eu não fiquei com medo
da pessoa não achei que ela ia me matar
porque aborda não tem isso de ver a
pessoa achar que a pessoa vai agredir
ela fazer alguma coisa de mal eu estou
muito bom humano naquele dia e foi só o
bom dia para algumas pessoas
hoje eu tô aqui pra falar pra vocês o
seguinte
quais são seus limites você se você já
tiver esse momento de se perguntar quais
são os limites de vocês qual sonho que
você já desistiu eu não desistir de
nenhum eles morreram sozinhos
vou dizer pra vocês uma coisa limites
são colocados nas nossas vidas para
serem ser superados e os nossos sonhos
eles são renovados a cada dia a cada
manhã
eu tenho pra dizer pra vocês hoje tente
sempre melhor
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]